yeah three seconds per move is also what
uh what does it okay
okay 2400 let's focus we are playing a
23.79 guys
yar thank you so much teleportivo with
the tier one
and we are gonna play the king's indian
okay all right guys
i'm a little concerned this guy has won
like
50 out of his last 52 games but
okay so h6 i don't know what this is
this is a weird move we're just gonna
chase the knight away i've never seen
this before
but we're going to give her the benefit
of the doubt 5 000 bits fidius gage holy
smokes
oh my lands girl bishop g7 okay
knight e5 okay uh fine
he's just shuffling his knight or a
knight c4
so this is a good um this is a good time
for me to practice what i preach
when our opponent does weird stuff like
that i'm not gonna change my strategy
i'm just gonna play normal moves i'm
just gonna develop my pieces
and let's let him die by his own sword
okay he's trolling so the knight on a5
let's apply
natural concepts is undefended what can
we do
our queen x-rays the knight that's
something you guys should see
so we can go c5 open up the attack on
the knight and
contest the center we're going to take
on d4 and we're going to very quickly
occupy the center with our pawns
yeah i don't like it when people do this
because that often means they start
playing really well at some point now
we're going to develop the knight and
sack the queen
some of you may have noticed that the
bishop x-ray is the queen but we
wouldn't have had a good discover check
okay queen on a4 how do we exploit it
what should we do
what should we do all right guys no
innocent until proven guilty right now
he's playing terribly
if he starts playing brilliantly i will
let you know e3
okay let's just wait and see so uh
you know we're gonna play normally here
uh there's many ways that we can
go about playing this uh the default
should be to just activate your pieces
so we're going to activate the rook and
put it on the semi-open file
where it basically pressures the c2 pawn
and uh we're going to see how he
responds to the queen h4
get out of here get out get out and get
out of that get out of here
a non-smurf yeah anon would totally be
doing this queen to c4
okay um well
he's trying to confuse me but you know
it's very important thank you phineas
once again let's go 95 to centralize the
night
we're going to keep improving our pieces
marginally eventually something's going
to manifest itself now we're going to
bring the bishop into the game with
bishop f5
and we're going to tuck it away on g6
potentially
okay now this night on c3 you guys see
that night right
we want to make sure that night is gone
what should we do
we use our knight and we put it on e4
but let's focus on the game guys it
doesn't matter that he's trolling
this is good practice because you're
gonna you're gonna play people who are
like that
okay knight to b5 it's actually not that
easy to
refute his moves i i know that sounds
crazy let's get our queen into the game
let's get the big boys into the game
let's get the big boys into the game now
we're gonna park our bishop back on g6
yeah he's actually not playing that
belly i mean it's he's he's not
blundering anything
okay now he's attacking our knight we
gotta move our knight back back to c5
yeah i know it sounds absurd but he's
actually not blundering and now he's
playing well h4 is a good move
he's undermining our pawn
now what should we do here well what i'm
noticing here is the knight on b3 right
let's send our pawn into a5 let's try to
attack that knight
get it out of b3 so that the queen could
reinforce its attack on i don't like
this
one bit ladies and gentlemen but we'll
see
um we're still i mean black is better
here i you know knight takes c5 okay so
what should we take with
what should we take this
so i can take with a bunch of pieces i
can take with a rook
but let's take with the pawn to chase
away his knight his knight is his only
good piece
so using logic we're gonna take with a
pawn but knight p5 would be a good move
here
that one i actually didn't quite
anticipate
okay let's slice off the connection
to his knight with a pawn holy smokes 10
bucks thank you so much
ethan olden appreciate it okay he
defends the knight
um let's get a rook into the game let's
get our last remaining piece into the
game of the lookout to d8
and we are already setting up a
potential knight sacrifice on d3
okay so he goes knight d4 so one thing
that i would consider doing here
if from a gm level is actually to
sacrifice the knight this is dania's
style
i'm not gonna do quite as much
explaining as i usually do because i'm
a little bit bemused okay let's go
knight d3 check sacrificing the night
why do i do this because
i feel like i have so many active pieces
that this has to work
look at all of my pieces in the game
we've talked about the scenario before
okay so what should we do now
hmm this knight is the annoying piece
this knight is the annoying piece i'll
give you guys a hint
let's get this knight out of the picture
e5
we could have taken with the bishop but
i don't want to give away my really nice
bishop
okay ah that's a very good move though
because eddie he wants to play e4 and he
wants to lock things up he sacrifices
back the piece
and he wants to lock everything up
that's a really strong idea now we're
going to bring the rook up to defend the
pawn on g5
we're going to bring the rook up to
defend the pawn on g5 i think i'm still
doing fine here
queen to e2 okay
um let's double on the c file
let's double on the c file
[Music]
and now um let's uh let's snag the pawn
let's
snag the pawn on b2 all right guys relax
everybody
queen to a2 he attacks our queen we move
our queen away
and now um well
i think we can take another pawn queen
takes a four
okay uh now i think that we can uh
hmm what should we do here
well i think that one thing we can do is
we can uh we can try to trade rooks we
can try to create a pair of bricks get
his active rook
out of its active square i did kind of
blunder the pawn but that's a
worthy price to pay for getting us rid
of his activities he of course takes it
uh yeah uh hmm now let's get our rook to
an open
file rook b7
okay f4 makes a lot of sense
okay queen a3 i'm gonna try to set this
up
okay what is this oh bishop d2
of course okay well i can drop my bishop
back that's okay
f6 oh my god rook h7 and e5 yeah
well you guys can see the difference you
know when okay but bishop g5 wait a
minute
let's not give up yet i want to take on
i want to take on d2 i don't see a
defense for him
i don't see a defense for him rook
here check
mmm wait a minute this is unclear
actually i might be winning
no something is up but i don't know what
it is exactly queen d6 e5
oh my god and if he takes and he's got
is he checkmating me there
oh my god that's ridiculous actually
let's play king f8 let's get the king
out
no no 2700 plays like this guys
i don't know the other thing is some
people play like this they psych me out
queen h5 is an amazing move because he
wants e5
but i can give him a check
i gotta try to flag him here king g4
oh my god damn girl
now he's got this check and he wins
oh my god yes and queen f7 three seconds
on that move
and then three seconds e5 oh hi
e5 oh my god it's hilarious
[Music]
rook c8 and bishop d8 is mate
oh my god that's so funny guys i mean
this guy is actually hilarious
oh my god he blunted her up wait i think
he turned it off
oh my god no it's me holy smokes
it's actually mate he wins king c7 he
had bishop f4 and he thinks in this
position
oh my god that's actually so funny guys
okay let's i gotta practice what i
preach
we're not gonna report him we're gonna
look with stockfish
a point i wanna make to everybody how do
you deal with something like this before
you report anybody
we have to leave the possibility that i
was so psyched out by this
that he made a bunch of mistakes and i
thought they were computer moves because
we had made up our minds so let's first
look with chess base and our real stock
fish
obviously what makes this suspicious is
the fact that he crushed me
out calculated me and he
uh he did it after a horrible opening
when he was lost
not a lot of people could do that but uh
we have to leave that possibility open
so let us um
practice that and look at the game
obviously um it is he made it extremely
extremely obvious what he was doing
but we have to practice innocent until
proven guilty
it's magnus would not play like this
that's what you guys need to understand
it
it's not about oh this guy could be
magnus it's the playing style
the playing style is what makes this the
most improbable it has nothing to do
with
oh if it was magnus then he could play
like this magnus doesn't play like this
look guys
you understand what i'm saying yeah and
that's a very typical technique that new
people have been doing which is to play
nonsense moves at the start
to evade the automated suspicion because
it will show a very low accuracy
because he played terribly at the start
you understand what i'm saying
and then once he starts doing it um
then he's quote unquote evaded suspicion
what he doesn't realize is he's playing
me
okay so i've i've set up the scene yeah
so danny has talked about it but
basically
five bucks thank you easy now we knew
that we would uh we would encounter
these kinds of people and
and and that's okay okay let me just um
so i don't actually think i played badly
either that's the funny thing i think i
played quite well
okay so you guys now can see stockfish
okay so let's look at stockfish
92 is really good okay
so let's go from this position so he's
minus three which is winning
rook c8 quinn h4 queen c4 okay let's
start here
let's start here queen e2
knight c3
knight v5 is top look at this knight b5
guys
knight 5 d4 is second f3
is fine although h4 is
basically top eight this is a mistake hg
and knight takes c5
is second yep no that's first now first
or second
knight b5 a4 is first or second
we're gonna go by the top two moves
because he could use a slightly
different computer
oh you know he's losing here i'm
actually winning i actually came very
close to beating him
so and this was a mistake e5 was a
mistake i should have gone rook c2
bishop d3 is top e4 stop
queen e2 bishop d2
king f2 is top top
top top
i don't know
f6 is top though rook h7
rook h5 is top okay yeah he definitely
cheated
quinn h5 is top top bishop g5
and now he had this smurf move brook b8
yeah so basically he he he went on and
off like he made some moves on his own i
came very close to beating him
nonetheless
i missed one big chance here um
i made i missed one big chance your rook
c2 would have been very strong
yeah i just didn't realize that this was
winning but obviously uh
681 volt yeah no no it's obvious that he
cheated
uh i won't even pretend to have any
suspicions
we'll report him um
and uh this is yeah he made it he made
it very very obvious
with three seconds of move and how he
played in the end that's what makes it
obvious
yeah three seconds per move is also what
uh what does it okay
i'll write them a personal message sorry
guys did you have to sit through this
i hope that i have been reasonable and i
hope i didn't make the accusation in an
unfounded manner i've shown my method
uh to be very clear the reason that i am
confident that he cheated consists of
several things
the first is that he played a terrible
opening followed by
an abundance of computer moves and
critical moments three seconds per move
and mainly i would not have been uh
convinced
had we not seen his play in the final
stage of the game this is where he
started playing topmost
look at his time four seconds four
seconds
five seconds one second four eight
seconds
seven seconds four seconds 20 seconds on
the best move four seconds on king q4
four four four four it's the typical
sign in rook ba nobody would ever play
this move
he knows that it's winning but he gives
up the rook
just to kind of smurf the engine okay
no it's not possible trust me on this
one
okay that is unfortunate um that this
happens
but um yeah so i was winning with rick t
now i knew this would be sketchy too
once he played knight g5 you already
know
something's gonna be wrong
maybe
and unfortunately yeah we knew we knew i
knew too but i have to
i have to give people the benefit of the
doubt you know
i can't make any conclusions
[Music]
now and before i get off the soapbox and
play one last one
i want to make one thing very clear
which is that if you guys
are playing a cheater i want to really
want to make this fleet from the bottom
of my heart
do try to give people the benefit of the
doubt not because i'm trying to be
holier than that but because
i co take take my word for it firsthand
uh to get accused of cheating when you
didn't cheat is
very frustrating very dangerous um and
and we want to make sure that
not as frustrated as you may be in the
frustration as human i feel that
that anger in my chest when i feel like
somebody's cheating it's terrible
uh but you do want to go by the evidence
and
you want to give the people the benefit
of the doubt uh and
and you know you have to understand that
sometimes the anger can come from a
normal place
but sometimes people truly can play well
and i'm not trying to garner any
you know any points for manuel he's so
moral but
i've made this mistake myself and uh i
feel like this is the best way to be
thank you twitch prime username
okay it really is innocent until proven
guilty and we have to practice that in
chess too
okay that's why i decided to show my
exact method
which is to check with stockfish and to
look at his time consumption
per move which is very very revealing
chess.com will do the rest
okay um well obviously the consequences
can be that you could falsely bend but
chess.com
is a great algorithm they don't do that
but that's just the mentality that i
advocate to everybody why not take
white bishop a few moves ago um
well if i took the bishop where oh you
mean here
well because if you take the bishop he's
got queen e5
followed by bishop b5 i mean the insane
thing
i mean all rook h5 is pretty insane
although it's understandable but to
realize that this is losing and this is
made it's crazy
and then king g4 instantly is is just
remarkable like windy six
oh wait i played this really good move
if you're a human you would calculate
king h2
i don't even know why you didn't play
this move king g4 instantly is
ridiculous
next game guys let's move on i think
we've all had our moment of fun
this will happen a couple of times uh in
the speed run and that it is what it is
okay let's go well twitch prime um
uh you know i'm perfectly calm just uh
you know yeah okay
so let's go up let's go on and i knew
that when a 2400 plays a 2000
that's already pretty sus to be good
that was a really good game king h2
queen d65
2258 thank you kalis kintodra
okay let's try another king's indian
let's try another king's indian
back to the game guys okay so we're
going to play the king's indian he plays
the fiance variation
he plays the fiance variation now i've
explained the main moves in the king's
indian many times
and in terms of where you develop this
knight
there's two possible squares c6 and d7
and one
important thing about playing the king's
indian at a high level the the move
knight c6
can sometimes backfire what is the
reason
what annoying response does white have
against knight c6
and that is the move d5 exactly so
knight bd7 is actually
very typical in the king's indian to
prepare e5 that knight is very safe
but i hear you guys saying well what
about the bishop on c8 we're going to
get that bishop
in due time and i'm going to show you
guys a really interesting line here we
go c6 to control the d5 square
and the other idea of the move c6 is to
deploy the queen to a5
this is my main line actually and at the
right moment we take on e5
and now we put the knight on e5 this is
all fury so i'm going a little bit fast
but every one of these moves i hope is
understandable too now we attack the c4
button and pressure his center
as you guys can see this is a hyper
modern opening because he's got a lot
more of the center than i do
but look at how i'm attacking both of
his pawns with my pieces this night
pressuring that pawn
this night pressuring that pawn and what
the battle is going to revolve around
here is
whether or not he's going to be able to
beat
back my initiative now we need to deploy
our rook to e8
in order to prepare to increase the
pressure on the e-pawn
if we want him to play f4 that's a move
a lot of people would play automatically
could somebody explain to me the
drawback of the move f4
okay um let's move on we'll do that
after the game
let me write this down okay
so now what we need this knight on d4 is
very active
can we try to compel him to get this
knight out of the picture
and we also accomplish a secondary goal
of increasing the pressure on the e pawn
and we also develop a piece so we do a
lot of things now c5 guys would be a
very common mistake
c5 would weaken the d5 square very
significantly
okay c5 would weaken the d5 square let's
find a slightly more subtle method of
doing it
well queen c5 ooh queen c5 is actually a
really good move
oh yeah yeah guys we're moving on wait a
minute i actually saw something really
cool
let me think
let's do this this is a very tricky move
guys
i thought of bishop e6 initially bishop
e6 was what we wanted to play initially
but now
somebody suggested this move i really
like it queen c5
now what is the idea i'm posing a thread
i'm x-raying f2 what are we specifically
50 bucks off season cornbread so glad
that it's helping you thank you so much
for the 50.
the bomb ladies and gentlemen from
cornbread we're threatening queen takes
d4 and knight f3 how did i see that
how does my brain spot that quickly well
the key sign guys when the bishop when
he's played g3 and the bishop is not
fianchettoed
that's a warning sign in your med
tactical metal detector
okay when the move g3 has been played
but the bishop has left its fiancee
square
the f3 square is often the source of
tactics and i'll show you guys after the
game
a really beautiful idea in this line
where that is applied
okay that's just a little thing to kind
of remember he actually
is doing a good job thinking here
because he's in pretty big trouble i
think
well let's see what he does
he's not lost but he's in trouble
well if this should be three then okay
ladies and gentlemen queen takes d4 and
the game is over
okay
so yep
now um this is the fianchetto variation
so queen a5 is actually the move that i
play as my main move
if we look in chess base uh
i will practice what i preach uh and
that's the fundamental
motivation here if we look if we do a
search on this position
in chess space and uh let me go into the
chess-based scene if we go into the
chess base scene and sorry guys i keep
doing this but
you guys can see
that i've played it twice i've actually
played it more through different move
orders but i have a couple of games in
the database in this line
and that actually is my main line
against the fiance i won a nice game
here against ivan key
and i've played it for many years the
dude closed his account there we go
so back to uh the game just wanted to
show you
so essentially the queen is deployed to
a5
now 95 attacks the pawn on c4 we go
rookie 8 to deploy the rook now here's
the line
if white goes bishop e3 here then we go
bishop e6
attacking the pawn trade and in this
position
i have many times encountered uh the
move a3 even anatoly karpov
all right guys moving on please moving
on all right this just is a thing
and it's only carpool into this i've
done this a million times black to play
and find a beautiful idea and the way
that you see this idea
is to spot the f3 score yes he closes
account guys but moving on please
black to play right queen b5
who sees it bingo battal for president
knight takes e4
i'll gift you a sub for that knight
takes c4 queen takes e1
knight f3 check is a four brilliant
tactic and knight takes e1 and at the
end of the day black's going to be up in
exchange
because if you take the knight i take
this knight
beautiful isn't it that's actually part
of the reason i like this movement five
believe it or not even if white plays f4
this is one of the main lines
black can still go knight takes c4 and
if f takes e5 knight g3 leads to
absolute chaos so to show this again a3
our idea is to get the queen on a
forkable square
okay that has to make sense for you guys
to follow this
the point is that if the queen ends up
on d2 or e1
we will be able to fork the queen how do
i know that this exists because once
again the bishop is not on its fiance
square
which means that the move g3 has now
weakened the f3 square
in order to get the queen in a forkable
square we open the gates i call this
like opening the gates
we distract the knight from c3 and we do
that in order to now
sacrifice our queen for the rook
boom now the queen is on a forkable
square our metal detectors go off
because the king and the queen are
unfortunate squares knight f3 check
king has to move we take the queen but
that's not the end of the story right
now if we count the pieces we have two
rooks
and two pieces against one rook and
three pieces so we're up in exchange
he would have had two pieces for a rook
but remember that his knight is now
hanging due to our rook being on e6
all right i've done this many times in
blitz games so remember four cribble
squares
and then distraction sacrifices yeah so
if after knight takes e4 he goes b4
then we can take on c3 and attack his
queen okay
glad you guys enjoyed it now the main
line by the way in this position for
that reason is to bring the king up
so king g2 would be a better way to do
what he did if he goes king g2 that
would be
that would have been a better idea king
h2 seems to defend against that
no no g3 is not bad but but this move
it doesn't actually solve the problem it
just makes it equally bad
okay and that's why we played queen c5
so why couldn't he take my queen with
his queen because it's the same exact
concept knight f3 check
and we win his queen back and we're up a
piece this came from the fiance
variation of the king's indian which is
by the way a very good variation if you
play it well
king h1 would be also good uh king each
one would be the same idea but this
would leave the f2 pawn unattended
so the move queen c5 could still be
considered here that's why king g2 is
good
because the king simultaneously defends
all these coupons
well i think he thought i think that he
thought he was somehow defending against
uh certain ideas he just didn't think
this through he didn't realize that the
square was still undefended
he should have gone bishop e3 and at
least given up a pawn and at least he
can continue to play although this is
terrible because white has also given up
his fiance bishop
well nanuka queen b6 doesn't pose the
secondary threat of attacking the pawn
so here white could even slide his king
to g2 and we can't take
that pawn don glover thank for the prem
what was the purpose of knight a4 if he
hadn't played queen takes d4 well he was
attacking my queen
you know he wanted my queen out of c5
which is understandable
i think you just failed to detect that
this was a threat
all right
glad to hear that shikhar thank you all
right guys i'll give you guys one more
encore game i'm pretty high energy right
now for some reason
i love doing this this gives me a lot of
energy as does the support
of everybody here another thank you for
the 50 bucks from off season cornbread
we got 500 bits on top of it from
fenvine gold
amazing okay
no i play knight bd7 as my full-time
line i love john
i love fed um but
you know i've played the king's indian
my whole life i still play it
knight bd7 is in pretty good theoretical
shape right now
yeah my book on positional chess is out
of print i'll try to investigate that
let's go
i'm i am high energy right now dude this
is
these hours is what i live for well
thank you uh
you it means so much for me to hear that
and i'm honestly so happy that
the people are enjoying this uh again
also great that people can come together
over this i'm very happy to be doing
this thank you dog yotera for the for
the prime
lovely i can definitely be bribed with
subs that's for sure
i appreciate it man